to be at the epicenter of something like
The Hangover
when that hits
did that affect you in any way that I
mean I have obviously it was a great
thing for your career but how did you
because you're such a
you're such a uh solid seeming uh person
and you're such a you're you're yeah I
mean you do seem like
someone who would not be buffeted by The
Winds of attention and fame but that
that hangover film came out I don't know
how you did you it was just one weekend
going insane it was a tornado of Fame
and yeah yeah to yeah a lot of buffeting
um
uh yes the it it was very overwhelming
uh but I also I I feel very lucky on
that as well because
um
I had my my public Persona had
risen gradually and we had like when I
was on basic cable on The Daily Show we
had what Colbert liked to call toy Fame
which is like you can still walk around
and do anything and you don't get really
recognized very often but occasionally
you do and someone at the airport who
works at like Einstein Bagels will be
like this one's on the house that's like
toy Fame and then then I got on the
office and I was on the office for a
couple of years before the hangover and
that was another
ratchet up because that's Network
television and I was definitely getting
recognized a lot more and Andy had weird
catchphrases which of course UPS the
ante with public recognition right
people shouting things at you Big Tuna
yeah exactly but uh and
um you know just a baggage claim just
people shouting that and that still
happens uh quite regularly but um
so I had I had a little bit of
um I had some skills set I I guess and
just in sort of dealing with that but
then the hangover was a whole new level
like like when the hangover came out it
was so exciting
um and another way in which I was lucky
on that one lucky in 10 million ways on
that movie but but Bradley and Zach and
I were all kind of at the same level
before that and so we were going through
it together and I really like if it
wasn't for those guys I don't think
I would have stayed sane but we all had
each other to kind of be like you know
I don't know just a
commiserate and and measure ourselves
and just be like okay who's being and I
think we kept each other from drifting
too far right and being too
unprofessional like I don't know it
wasn't a spoken thing it wasn't like we
held each other accountable by yelling
at each other or anything but it was
like if somebody was out of line or got
you know a little too big for their
britches it you could feel it on the set
and everyone would just sort of like
settle back in of course correct course
correct exactly and it was a from a deep
place of like
um of like we've been we're going
through this thing together like a yeah
a bond it was such a unique experience
and
I I look back on it and wish and it's a
classic thing of like I wish I knew more
I wish I could go through it again with
what I know now because because I don't
think I I really was reeling a lot of
the time like in the aftermath of The
Hangover just kind of like
get like how I was handling my my I was
getting scripts for all these different
kinds of projects like what do I do I
don't know I was kind of spinning out
and panicking about different things
like uh like well what kind of a career
do you want I don't I just want to do
comedies right well I don't know this is
a pretty killer drama coming your way
and just all these weird conversations
with agents and Reps and trying to
figure out right I I definitely felt a
lot of
um
anxiety and like identity kind of uh
just
turmoil and I will say one of the one of
the craziest things about a about us
like massive jump into Fame like that is
uh and this and this is what I think
people who
um have never dealt with that or been
close to it
and just can't understand is the just
total loss of control of your
environment so when you are a famous
person uh you can't
uh you just can't stand it baggage claim
and have expect it to be normal and so
you a lot of times you can there are a
lot of ways to approach that you can get
very fearful and try to like hide in the
bathroom until you see your luggage come
out on the Carousel and then run out and
grab it and run away or you know hire
lots of people to do all these things
for you or
you know which I and I think the best
thing is to just kind of like accept the
fluid nature of these situations and and
except that the stakes really are never
quite as high as you think they are kind
of in your mind and just roll roll with
it and that was that's been a very
positive I think lesson beyond the even
the fame question it was just like in an
approach to life it's just being that
kind of like the river like just flowing
yeah in in those cities I I agree uh
completely you are amen I say to you
because it's not Taylor Swift's fault
that she can't go into uh a Chuck E
cheese and and uh
um I just know that that's what she
wants to do because we're friends but
um no no she can't because she's still
there aren't people yeah yeah yeah
some very very very salty ones well she
and Chucky have a bag
she wrote lots of songs about Chucky
doing her wrong
um the guy's a rat
he is he's literally is a rat
um but uh but no I I think so I do have
sympathy for people like that uh but I
know that
um
um like at my you know lower level I
know that when people see me and they go
hey Conan I go hey how are you and they
go like oh and they say something nice
but I like the podcast or you know
thanks for the laughs they go what's
your name and they'll go like oh Steve
and I go like Steve thanks I appreciate
you know you you make it normal and then
they're they're fine that's all they
want I think it's about control like
control makes us feel safe and uh and
yet we you can you actually if you can
relinquish control truly and you you
will be feel so much more free and safe
and that's it's incredibly difficult
thing to do
um when you know you're going from a a
unknown person to a very very well-known
person literally changes reality like it
changes yeah how the world responds to
you and I always thought it was funny
like people would be like you know when
you get famous they're like Don't Go
Changing and you're like well kind of
everyone else is changing in how they're
interacting with me right so
uh how can you even tell like am I the
same are they is everyone like people
that I've known for 20 years are
suddenly nervous around me or like you
know acting weird and and you can't tell
them Don't Go Changing like what what's
the what's what's different it's so hard
to parse and figure out but I do I I got
to a point where I realized like this
it's my
desire to control this that's driving me
nuts yep and the once I relaxed into it
and and settled into it more and like
you said just being sort of gentle and
genuine with people for the most part as
long as their energy is nice then
it just goes fine yeah it really goes
okay I mean I often I'm at the stage now
where I have to tell people who I am
yeah and try and get them to yeah try
and get them to approach it you just go
to the baggage carousel even when you're
not flying yeah I spend a lot of time at
the barrage get at the baggage carousel
and I haven't flown in quite a while I
was at and I hold a sign that says Conan
O'Brien well no I I actually saw you at
LAX the other day yelling at someone to
leave you alone and he was walking away
from you yeah and I I said leave me
alone I'm Conan O'Brien and I want my
privacy yeah and he just was right he
ran to his cars yeah it was very no no
it's that's become its own problem I've
created my own negative energy by um
trying to force it too much and that was
your son okay you went too far well your
improv add-on was just insane
um my father